Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you Ruffians for joining us today for our 59th episode!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, are you awake?
What?
Really?
It's been a little bit of a rough 24 hours, FUWAMOCO-chan.
But thank you, Ruffians, for joining us!
Maybe there's some first-time Ruffians out there, too.
Well, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short-format morning show that will be Friday, Wednesday, and Monday!
Monday!
It's not Monday today, Moco-chan.
Today, it's Wednesday!
Yeah.
Friday, Wednesday, Monday.
Is also known as FUWAMOCO.
Yeah.
FUWAMOCO Morning is hosted by us!
FUWAMOCO!
Say FUWAMOCO again!
FUWAMOCO.
FUWAMOCO!
I aim is to bring a smile to your face.
I hope you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
It's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Don't mock me, okay?
I won't mock you.
It's my duty as a little sister, right, Ruffians?
I have the right to mock.
I don't think so.
Uh-huh.
Well!
The Ruffians, apparently, they saw Pero again.
Again?
Really?
Where is he this time, hoi?
Well, let's see.
De-den!
Ruffians, look!
Pero has a new part-time job.
This time, he's doing the heartless work of being a Santa who has numerous kids sit on his lap and listen to what kind of toys and presents they want for Christmas.
Ruffians, do you want to take a photo on Pero Santa's lap?
Do you want to take a photo with Pero Santa?
What do you think it'll feel like?
I'm just curious, you know, would it be squishy?
Would it make a sound?
But he's a muscle.
It could still be squishy.
Hmm.
Well, you do!
What?
What legs?
He looks jolly?
I usually don't mean jelly.
I think Pero, you know, does he need legs?
What?
Does he need legs?
He has wings, those are like skylights.
Yeah, well, you know, Pero-san said he did bring us and the other Advent girls some gifts for Christmas, but he would never bring us what we wanted.
You know, sometimes it was a bit disappointing to be honest.
We're just happy to receive something, right?
Because he probably tried his best.
Ruffians!
Do you know what you're asking for for Christmas?
Do you?
It's very important.
You know, you better get ready before Moco Santa comes to town.
Okay, I'll get ready.
Good health, that's a good one.
Steak and wine, not a bar of soap, are you sure?
Well, Muffins, you better get thinking, okay?
There's not much time, not much more time!
BAU BAU!
Well, that's an interesting job, huh?
It'd be fun, maybe.
Yeah, I think so, Moco-chan.
You wouldn't want to do that.
I don't know.
It's tough being a Santa, huh?
Well!
We have some exciting news!
Ruffians!
Tonight, we have the very first in a double upload of cover solo songs!
Tonight!
We released our cover of Shiro's Cute no Kanojo back in October, right?
But I think Ruffians liked it quite a bit, right?
Maybe.
Just maybe.
Thank you for all the feedback!
We love you, Ruffians!
But tonight, at 6pm PT, we'll be releasing a FUWAMOCO solo version, followed by a FUWAMOCO!
Followed by me, Mococo!
A Moco-chan version at the same time tomorrow, you know?
And then you'll be able to listen to both of them very closely and get a good feel for the differences in our voices and, you know, our creative expressions, too.
You know, sometimes it can be a bit tricky for some Ruffians, so maybe this will be a helpful guide in a sense.
But you know...
I'm so curious to see whose cover will be more popular.
Get listening, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
Exciting!
Well, also exciting is...
The homework we gave you.
That's right, Moco-chan.
We gave homework.
Ruffians!
Did you finish it yet?
We mentioned it last FUWAMOCO Morning, but we need your help again.
You know, on Monday, we asked you to share your favorite holiday or Christmas memory with us, right?
You remember, right?
Right!
Yeah!
No forgetting.
Yeah, we wanted to learn a little bit more about you.
And so we're hoping that you'll share some of your memories with us and the Ruffians too.
You can't finish it?
I think you mean I can finish it.
Yeah, you are.
Well, we opened up a Google Form for you to fill in.
There's only a few simple rules.
Only a couple.
BAU BAU!
I see hope.
I see hope that you haven't forgotten your memories.
It might be hard to get to them all, but... But!
You have until Saturday, December 21st at 6pm PT to submit yours, okay?
That part is slow because it's very, very important, okay?
Yeah.
And Moco-chan, where can you find that?
You can find the link right underneath us in... In my tag!
Right...
Right underneath us!
In the description box, okay?
There's a link there.
Okay.
And also on Twitter too, right?
And Twitter, yeah.
Yeah.
So you better get writing, Ruffians!
Go at it!
Actually, maybe Ruffians, do you have any good ideas right now?
Good ideas for memories to share, maybe?
Maybe that will make some other Ruffians... Oh!
Where was that?
Don't share other Ruffians' memories.
Not really, ha!
You do?
Oh, you're gonna keep it a secret, though?
You have to turn your ears down.
That's okay, that's okay.
Nice to meet you.
Oh no, spoilers!
Are you secret?
I'm not sure they're interesting enough though.
I'm sure your memories are interesting, okay?
I'm sure they are.
Who got a dog for Christmas?
Like, you got a new family member?
One of my favorites is drinking hot chocolate with my kitty!
We wanna hear those memories, okay?
Please submit them, okay Ruffians?
Those are all great.
We're looking forward to the cozy time hearing all about those memories and moments, okay?
BAU BAU!
Well, you know, almost as soon as it becomes the new year, there is the big hololive New Year Card!
The big Mario Card Tournament!
You know what?
This year, it'll be taking place on the 7th and the 8th!
Yeah!
And you know, us, FUWAMOCO, will be participating in it for the first time, of course!
Yeah.
And unlike the Minecraft Sports Day Tournament back in November, if you remember.
I remember.
This time, we're participating separately!
And you know, we're separated into separate teams, because that's what happens when you participate separately.
Yeah.
Moco-chan, Abyss,
I was gonna ask if we could share what groups we were put into, but... It's BAU.
Wow, Ruffians!
Moco-chan is in the Able!
And myself, Fuwawa, I'm in the D.Va!
What do you think of the team's hall, Ruffians?
Good placement.
Is it suited for us?
Do you think we have a chance to win?
D-D is scary.
Fuwawa, D, Mococo, A, that is the block placement.
Yeah.
Sorted by random.
Random.
Yeah.
Towa-senpai is random.
Okai-senpai on the wheel.
Sorted by Okai-senpai and Towa-senpai randomly.
Yeah.
Just what?
Just like what?
What's that?
D group is chaotic.
Hmm.
Regardless, we're going to do our best.
But we do have a lot of practicing to get through before so that we can catch up to our senpai.
They've been many years, right?
Yeah.
You know, we'll do our best still.
But one thing is for sure!
Is that we're going to have the most fun!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
That's for sure.
I'm looking forward to it.
It's going to be fun, okay?
Yeah.
Well, Ruffians, it's not just my yukkuri that's coming up, but you know, the end of the year is almost here.
Do you know what that means?
I'm curious.
Do you know?
There's something that FUWAMOCO is really excited about.
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
Well, maybe you should pay attention.
That Ruffian!
Don't touch the morning air!
I'm sorry Ruffian, I touched you.
She's chasing the Ruffian with her finger.
That Ruffian!
Stop.
At the end of the year.
It's Winter Comic Market!
And you know what?
This year.
Well, Moco-chan, what is comics?
Okay, well, to explain first, so, in case you don't know, Comic Market is Japan's biggest fan comic convention where they sell doujinshi and other fan-made indie works, you know?
So it's not just comics.
It could be things like music or merchandise or even just, you know, written works about what kind of gyoza they like or their own homemade recipes.
It could be anything, okay?
And in the industry, there's also an industry, everyone.
I guess they'll be official.
Hold on!
Yeah, it's super fun.
Very free.
You know, there's, of course, cosplay too.
Lots of stuff going on.
You really, really don't know what you might discover.
Endless possibilities.
We love Comiket.
But, FUWAMOCO, us, Mococo, we're going to be making our Comiket debut at Icomochi-mama, so cool!
Moco-chan, what's a circle?
You know, a circle is like a... Circle's a shape.
Yeah, it is a shape.
But, you know, it's what you call a comic group.
But yeah!
Icomochi-mama!
She's releasing an unofficial FUWAMOCO fanbook set!
And we're really excited!
You know, look at the cute blanket too.
You know, we've also been seeing some other very creative Ruffians getting ready for their own FUWAMOCO related books and comic book day.
So we can't wait!
Creative Ruffians.
You're gonna send us a copy too, right?
Right.
Right?
Right!
Of course, right!
You know, like we said in our debut, we want to get our paws off FUWAMOCO!
Yeah!
We said that!
Yeah, but...
But you know, we're still looking forward to seeing all the Ruffian spoils of war done.
Yeah!
Because Comiket is mine!
BAU BAU!
Have fun!
Exciting!
Very very exciting.
Comiket is so fun.
It's chaos, it's war, but it's fun.
Very fun.
You know it's also, it's not the end of the year, it's kind of close to the end of the year.
It's the holiday season.
So Ruffians, naturally, you've been eating a lot of chocolate recently.
Naturally!
Right?
Not FUWAMOCO though, no chocolate for us, but... What about chocolate wafers?
Have you been having any of those?
No!
Now, well, maybe it's time that you should.
Because Ruffians, starting in April, you'll be able to find us, Advent, and a bunch of our senpai packed together as cards along almost any kind of candy place.
Do you think you'll be able to find us?
Yeah.
FUWAMOCO is here!
Candy for FUWAMOCO!
We're gonna be in accord with the candy.
We won't become the candy.
But we're really looking forward to it!
Try your best to get FUWAMOCO, okay?
You know, I... You might have to get a lot of wafers first, huh?
Yeah, you might have to eat them.
Yeah, but... I hope you like wafers!
They're delicious!
That's April.
April.
You still have some time to move to Japan!
You still have time, okay?
Yeah, you know... April.
Ohikoshi wa mada.
Ari desu.
BAU BAU!
Oh, I'm excited for those.
Chocolate.
But we don't know what flavor it's gonna be though, so... There's so many possibilities.
I bet it, Ruffians, it's gonna be your favorite flavor.
For sure.
Exciting.
It's been exciting.
It's been good, but... Ruffians... I kinda did... I did something.
I did it.
He did.
I messed up.
There's been... Another misunderstanding.
There goes our combo.
Do you ever say something that's, like, wrong, but you think, well, everyone understands, so it's fine, right?
And then you continue to say that all the time?
That happens to us a lot.
Yeah, just a bit.
Yeah, well...
Ah, that's why, you know, I described our sneezes as having different flavors the other day while we were reading Super Chats after playing Chillin's Art.
Snooze game!
Jishatsu!
You know, because...
Ichibou.
Sneezes have different flavors to them.
Yeah, like personality, you know, personality.
Personality.
Not like an actual taste.
No.
No, of course, of course not.
That's gross, Ruffians.
Very, very gross.
Yeah, and it's not like you can taste the flavor when you sneeze.
I'm hot.
Right, Moco-chan?
I don't know.
I feel like I can smell more.
Uwabi sneeze.
What?
Uwabi.
I mean, I feel like after sneezing I can smell more.
I don't know if that counts though.
That doesn't count, no.
Ruffians, you understand me, right?
There's a personality in every sneeze.
That makes sense, right?
Not flavor, though.
Just personality.
Each of our sneezes have a different personality to them.
Yeah, like a spicy sneeze.
But that's a flavor, though.
I'm just confusing the Ruffians more, aren't I?
Ruffians, you understand, right?
We're trying to clear up the misunderstanding, not make more.
You understand, right?
Understood?
Understood.
Do they understand?
Just smile and say understood.
Understood!
BAU BAU!
I'm glad the Ruffians are so understanding.
Right?
Me too.
Wow, Ruffians.
How are you feeling about this week so far?
Has it been a little rough maybe?
How's it?
I wouldn't know anything about that.
No, not at all, huh?
Uh-uh.
Well, Moco-chan, maybe the Ruffians could use a little extra popping and stuff.
Well... Ruffians!
Can you get a bit closer?
You know, there's something I wanna say!
You know what this is, right?
This here is a Mococo Pup Talk!
And you're gonna hear it straight from me, Mococo!
Ruffians!
You know, sometimes it can be rough, right?
No matter how hard you try, things just don't go your way.
You know?
No matter how much you prepare, your plans get a wrench thrown in them.
Sometimes, you really can't prepare and expect what's gonna happen the next day no matter how hard you try to be ready for the unexpected.
And you know, that's okay!
Because that's just how life is!
But, you know what?
You have a secret trick to you!
You're resilient!
You're super strong!
Despite how you feel sometimes, when things get rough, you actually get tougher!
Don't you think that's amazing?
So, no matter how difficult and frustrating things can be at this busy time of year, don't worry, don't sweat the small stuff, and you know what?
You'll be okay.
Even if you don't have everything under control,
You do have some things under control.
And that's good enough.
Okay!
You know, it sounds kind of silly, but let's enjoy the punches that life sends our way to, okay?
You can do it, Ruffians!
You can do it!
Ganbaite ne!
BAU BAU!
You can do it, Ruffians!
And next!
We're gonna have a Doggie of the Day!
Moco-chan, who's the Doggie of the Day today?
We have... De-den!
We have Kobe!
Kobe is the Doggie of the Day!
This isn't this Ruffian's dog.
No, this is this Ruffian's friend's dog.
Yeah!
I guess that's acceptable, but... What do you mean?
He didn't say your Doggie of the Day, just our Doggie of the Day.
You know, Kobe is extra special because apparently he's a model for a vulgar... or dog?
Dog?
Yeah.
Are you sure about that?
You know, he kinda looks like he's made of cardboard.
Cardboard?
Well, you know, it's good to have lots of different doggies of all kinds, you know?
Especially cardboard ones.
Yeah, it adds flavor!
Flavor?
Not personality?
Flavor!
Very cute.
How does Kobe BAU BAU?
You know Kobe works for a dog store?
Maybe like...
Like that!
I don't know what this BAU BAU is, but sure, it can be Kobe's.
Kobe!
Kobe is ambitious.
He will show that he's cut out for the modeling industry.
Cut out of cardboard.
He's so cut out for it.
He even looks a little bit like a cutout.
Why?
Yeah, and you know what?
He's doing an amazing job.
BAU BAU!
Very cute cardboard.
Good boy.
Right?
BAU BAU!
And next for today I went on a walk, we have De-den!
What?
Oh my goodness!
This is beautiful!
It's so colorful!
This is downtown Mexico City!
Did you buy anything there?
You know, I don't know, it might be a bit silly, but you know, I actually really love looking at the lights at night, you know, so this illumination, I really like it a lot.
It looks like it was a lot of fun!
Thank you for sharing it with us!
BAU BAU!
Ah, next time we got a question from a Ruffian.
My question of the day is... De-den!
Good morning!
I'm always looking forward for the pup talk.
It gives me real power for an entire week.
I have a question.
Has FUWAMOCO's hair always had this length ratio?
Or has Mococo had it longer than Fuwawa's at some point?
BAU BAU!
This is another good question.
It's a good question.
Well, actually, at one point, when we were really little demon dogs, it was me.
I had long hair.
And I had short hair.
So it is strange, right?
Are you surprised, Ruffians?
But, you know, we much, much prefer it like this.
It works best like this, right?
We're the cutest now, just as we are right, Ruffians?
Right!
What's with the sock, Emily?
Huh?
Yes!
Yeah!
Right answer.
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much for all your submissions and for being a part of FUWAMOCO Morning along with us, Ruffians!
Thank you!
We're always looking for more Doggie of the Day!
For questions, questions, questions, questions.
I'm sure you have lots of questions.
For more walks, you know.
And especially the brand new FUWAMOCO scoop as well under the hashtag FWMCMORNING.
Thank you so much for always supporting us, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
And next!
Well, what we have upcoming next isn't a stream, but!
But!
We have!
Tonight at 6pm PT 11am JST, we're gonna be premiering our solo covers of Kyuuto no Kano-chan!
Today and tomorrow!
You know, so today is me, tomorrow is Moco-chan.
And then!
On Friday we'll be back bright and early with you for FUWAMOCO Morning!
It'll be a little bit of a wait, but we'll see you again soon, okay?
We'll be around, okay?
We will.
BAU BAU!
And if we take another peek at our schedule...
Busy Ruffians.
Well you know, Christmas is just about here.
And this weekend we have a lot of plans on Saturday.
Moco Santa's coming to town.
At FUWAMOCO we're gonna be going to Malaysia for Carnival Fiesta.
And then we're gonna be playing Among Us together with Alphard and our Ian-senpai.
And then, Sunday is Christmas Eve.
And we have some big plans with you!
So, we hope that you'll be able to spend a little bit of time with us.
Don't miss it, okay?
Even if it's just a little bit.
Okay.
Thank you, Ruffians!
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
Thank you again.
Thank you so much for joining us, Ruffians.
And thank you for also being so understanding.
We had to make a couple of changes to our schedule yesterday.
We really appreciate it.
Moco-chan.
I'm feeling a little bit better.
It's because of you, Ruffians.
Thank you.
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our extra special Ruffians today!
Nappi.
BAU BAU!
Reisu.
Remu.
BAU BAU!
Nojaru.
Jakku.
BAU BAU!
Chuudon.
This is power.
BAU BAU!
Kousuke.
Heropon X. BAU BAU!
Wapopo Sophie.
BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
AwesomeGuy97!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!